to come speak at the meeting
so this is joint work with my former phd
student constantino sianos and i am
going to tell you about consensus-based
distributed online prediction and
stochastic optimization
an alternate title could be achieving
order square root of m regret with
approximate distributed mini batches
okay so um
let me start out by telling you
what what is the stochastic online
prediction problem so that we're all on
the same page so we're going to be doing
prediction in an online manner so that
means we're going to make some
prediction w say time one and we're
going to receive some observation or
some some random samples from the world
and we're going to suffer some loss
which is a function of both the
prediction that we made and the
observation that we make
and at that point we can refine our
prediction maybe incorporate some
information that we gained
we'll make a new observation and suffer
a new loss and this is going to repeat
on and on and on
and the the way we're going to measure
performance is in terms of regret a
standard way to do this
we're going to operate under the
assumption that these
observations that we're making are all
drawn iid from some unknown distribution
and so
so that's going to be one of the
underlying assumptions and i'll tell you
more in a moment and the way that we're
going to measure performance that we uh
the way well yeah how we're performing
is in terms of this regret so this says
after we've made m predictions and
observations how well are we doing how
what is the uh loss or the regret that
we've accumulated relative to what we
would have accumulated if we were using
a predictor which minimizes the expected
value of this loss function with respect
to that unknown distribution so we don't
know w star and we want to try to find
something which is close to w star and
so the goal is to quickly find something
close to w star without accumulating too
much regret
okay
um and so there's a nice survey on this
by shallow shorts and many others have
done work on this area not citing all by
any means but it's a nice survey if
you're not familiar with the problem
so the assumptions that i'll be making
about the loss function for this talk
are that it's convex in uh in the
prediction parameter w so for any x f is
going to be convex
it's lip shit's continuous and it has
lipsticks continuous gradients
and the other thing i'm going to assume
is so we have iid observations x is our
id and so
that basically gives us that are the
gradients that we would take by
evaluating at these random observations
are unbiased and we're also going to
assume that they have a bounded variance
sigma squared these are standard
assumptions in this literature
all right and so i'm just repeating the
definition of regret there to remind us
what it is and so we also know from the
optimization literature and refinements
of it that the best one could hope to do
in this scenario is to have a regret
which grows like the square root of m
under the assumptions that i've made if
you make stronger assumptions you can
get better bounds but the best we can
hope for under this set of assumptions
for this class of functions is to have
regret which grows like the square root
of m and it's achieved by many
algorithms many first order algorithms
just using gradient-based information
in particular it's achieved by
nestorov's dual averaging algorithm and
that's something that we'll build on
later on in this talk okay
so now what is distributed online
prediction so the previous framework i
told you was in more of a sequential
setting or a serial setting one
processor receiving observations making
predictions but if you're operating in a
setting where the rate at which you need
to make predictions the rate at which
your observations are arriving is faster
than a serial processor can handle that
motivates going to a parallel or
distributed setting
so now the problem formulation is going
to be that we have some network of
processors each one is receiving its own
stream of observations x sub i at node i
and it also has to make predictions and
it's going to suffer loss
correspondingly for each of those
observations that it makes
and so these processors are going to be
connected in some form of a network
which we'll describe by a graph that
could be given to us it could be
something that we'll want to design but
we'll assume that it's connected
symmetric and and this is how we
communicate between different nodes by
passing messages over this graph
all right and so now in this setting the
way we'll measure performance or regret
is by saying we need to accumulate the
regret that
is is incurred by all nodes in the
network so we're going to have to sum
over all nodes i
and if the network has collectively
processed m
observations made m predictions
we're going to divide those m
observations uniformly over all nodes
and so each node has this m over n
predictions that it's made and our
regret otherwise looks very similar
okay
all right so again we would like to know
how how can we do in this distributed
setting now and so
clearly one could be
naive and try to completely avoid
communication and in
uh that would be ideal in the sense we
would save a lot of energy so it didn't
come out the right way that's not what i
was trying to say um but we could not
collaborate at all okay and so if we
don't collaborate at all then
what would we end up having well our
regret would scale like n times the
regret of a serial processor right and a
serial processor that only saw one nth
of the samples and so
that regret would scale like square root
of n times m so as we have more
processors even though we've seen the
total same amount of data
the regret is going to grow so we need
some collaboration but we do want to
keep it to a minimum
so with collaboration
we know
the best we can hope to do is as if we
had one
super processor that was streaming n
times faster than any individual
processor in which case we would get
this regret regret bound again
of
the regret growing like the square root
of m
okay which is the best we can hope to
take so so the question is really can we
do this and what is the minimal amount
of communication that we need in order
to accomplish this
okay and so how do we achieve this it
can be achieved
and so one approach to doing this was
proposed by alfred deckel and his
colleagues at microsoft and
what they observed was in the serial
setting now
what we could do is rather than
processing and updating our predictor
after every single observation let's
group together a batch what they call a
mini batch of observations let's say
that that batch is of size b
and so what we're going to do is use the
same predictor
so wb is still equal to w1 for those
first b
observations that we make
and we're going to do that so that we
can
aggregate our gradients so we're going
to
take the gradients at the same predictor
but for all of our different our first
batch of b observations
and so since these gradients are random
averaging averaging them is going to
reduce the variance and so that's going
to give us a more confident direction in
which we we can update our predictor but
at the same time we've accumulated this
loss over all of that mini batch of b
predictors and so it turns out in this
setting if you choose well if for an
arbitrary b you can show that the regret
is going to scale like o of b plus the
square root of m plus b i'm leaving out
the constants for the talk today
and so clearly choosing b appropriately
to be
less than square root of m or at most
order square root of m is going to give
you the same scaling in terms of your
regret
okay so this isn't interesting
necessarily in the serial setting but
the reason it's interesting if you're
not going to move into the parallel
setting is that
you can do this batching in parallel i
can say i'm going to give 1 over n of my
batch to each one of my processors and
do that in parallel to get some sort of
a speed up but if we do that then we
need to do some communication in order
to compute this average gradient
okay and so in the distributed mini
batch algorithm that declared all
proposed this is what they do
and they say we're going to distribute
the mini batch of b samples across our
end nodes
we're going to aggregate synchronously
along a spanning tree using something
like an all reduce operation so we're
going to compute the average and also at
the same time distribute that average
back to every other node in the network
okay so every node in this case is
exactly going to receive the average
and
the one thing to to be careful of here
is now while we're communicating so
remember we were motivated to go to the
parallel setting because the stream of
of predictions that we have to make was
arriving too fast for one processor to
handle and so while we're doing our
communication we still have to account
for the fact that additional
additional predictions are going to have
to be made and so we're still going to
be using our old predictor before we get
to do this update so there's some
latency in this communication and the
way that we can quantify that is to say
that during the time that we're
communicating
an additional
new samples arrive to the network and
need to be processed okay and so in this
case the regret
the definition of the grid is
essentially the same but it looks as
follows it says that
we've still processed with a network of
n nodes a total of m samples we've
divided those into a number of rounds
which is equal to the total number of
samples divided by the number of samples
that arrive to the network in one round
and that's the number b that we use to
compute one mini batch gradient plus the
additional number mu that arrive to the
network while we're aggregating this
gradient using something like an all
reduce
okay
and so this is divided up over n nodes
and so that number of total samples per
one round of the mini-batch algorithm is
also divided uniformly amongst the end
nodes we'll say okay that's what's going
on here and otherwise we're the same as
we were before
okay
and so
if we do this
um what they show is that we can achieve
the optimal regret still in this setting
by choosing the appropriate
appropriate
choice of this parameter b the size of
our mini batch so really what it tells
you is that your communication latency
in the end doesn't hurt you at least in
terms of the order-wise rate at which
your regret grows
okay so this is this is interesting now
because we're doing this in parallel and
so we're going to get the speedups the
benefits that we would hope to get by
using parallel computing
this is looking at uh
yeah mu staying constant essentially as
m goes to infinity right so so and
that's reasonable right um so the
question was
uh how does this depend on on mu sorry
yes so and the so the dependence on you
really is to say that the latency
um the amount of time it takes us to
aggregate one mini batch shouldn't
depend on how many total samples we've
seen over time right so this is
asymptotic as m goes to infinity so it's
going to stay
constant i agree with you 100 too that
it's going to depend on n and i'll come
back to that in a moment yeah so that's
really the cost of the communication
here
but we'll just leave it as a
a latency mu
i mean in short you would expect that if
you have n nodes and if you have a nice
balanced tree the depth of that tree is
log n and so the latency should be on
the order of log n right so mu is on the
order of log n but in the asymptotics as
m goes to infinity that doesn't hurt us
yeah okay
so the questions i wanted to think about
for this talk are do we need to exactly
compute the average
okay so
in this model that we've discussed so
far we do our mini batching and then we
synchronously compute the the average
over time and one would like to go about
doing this maybe in a more asynchronous
manner kind of randomly interleaving
gradient updates with
samples arriving to the network
all right and so
the motivation for this talk is to move
towards the fully asynchronous method
for doing this
okay
um
and so
let's let's be precise about what we
want to do when we're saying we want to
accomplish an approximate
distributed averaging in order to do
this so
just to make it concrete or i'll reduce
operation we can think of as being an
exact distributed averaging protocol in
the following sense if i call i'll
reduce and node i give some input y i
divided by n i'm thinking my i'll reduce
with the sum operator here then we're
going to add those up and every node is
going to get the sum right and so the
sum of these y i's over n is just
exactly the average and so we've
computed the average exactly at every
node
so in a approximate distributed
averaging protocol i'll say that i have
an approximate distributed averaging
protocol which gives me a delta accurate
average with
with latency mu
if
the output of this when i give it some
value y i at node i initially
is such that for every node i
if i compare that
output y i at node i to the average of
the initial values that they gave to
this all reduce this distributed
averaging protocol they're all within
delta of the average and so this is a
euclidean norm
and
still with some latency mu which is
going to be similar to the well it's
going to depend on the algorithm of
course that we use but it'll be in the
same sense measured in the same units as
the latency in the previous slide
okay and so the reason
i'm interested in going this route is
an alternative to using an all reduce
for computing and distributed averaging
is to use something like a gossip
algorithm
so briefly introduce gossip algorithms
i'll introduce a synchronous version and
then i'll tell you afterwards that
there are ways to make this completely
asynchronous i won't go into it in the
talk today though i can tell you about
that offline
so
here's the simple version of a gossip
algorithm it's really a linear iteration
we're going to assume that we have some
doubly stochastic matrix w
and that matrix w respects the the
topology of our network okay so in the
sense that an entry wij is larger than
zero if and only if we have an edge
between nodes i and j in our graph if
they communicate
and then we're going to repeat linear
iterations
of the form i've written up here so y y
could be a vector still but what we're
going to do is after the k plus first
on the k plus first iteration at node i
it's going to take some weight from its
previous iterate and it's also going to
add in some amount that it receives from
the other nodes j in the network now
because w i j
respects the topology the graph the only
non-zero terms in this sum are those
corresponding to neighbors of node i
and so essentially what this corresponds
to is node i sending its current iterate
to its neighbors receiving its current
iterate from its neighbors and then they
can all update this linear sum together
okay so this would be a synchronous
description of the algorithm each round
each of the k iterations of that gossip
algorithm would require communicating
one copy of the vector to each of its
neighbors and of course this could be
done in an asynchronous manner too
and then if you put sort of a
probabilistic model in how you achieve
asynchrony you get probabilistic results
but in this deterministic setting we can
say the following we can say that as
that number of iterations k
tends to infinity uh clearly the value
at every node is going to tend to the
average and this is one way to see this
is that w can be thought of as a
probability transition matrix of a
markov chain which has uniform
stationary distribution and so taking
powers of of that matrix is just going
to have every node converge to uniform
and so that gives us the average
and
if we only do a finite number of
iterations we're not going to get
exactly to the average but we can bound
the error at any node and we can say
that every node is going to be within
delta of the average if the number of
iterations that we take looks like log
of 1 over delta the accuracy that we
want to get to times the square root of
n it's the size of the network times the
worst case
distance that any node starts out from
the average
and this is also divided by one minus
the second largest eigenvalue of this
matrix this weight matrix w that we're
talking about so this is the spectral
gap if you're familiar with the rates at
which markov chains converge to their
stationary distribution this comes up
there too this essentially encodes
something to do with the structure of
the graph that we're we're doing this
gossip algorithm over the
it's related to a diffusion over this
graph as well and so if we have
something like a ring it's going to take
a long time for information to diffuse
from one end to the other and so the
spectral gap is going to be on the order
of n it's going to be the size of the
network
and so for something intermediate like a
random geometric graph or a 2d grid we
get things which look like square root
of n or square root of n over log n
and on the other hand if we have a
nice graph either a complete graph or an
expander graph
then
this inverse spectral gap or relaxation
time is is going to be of the order of
constant regardless of the size of our
network so that's maybe the most
interesting case if you can design your
network then design it to be something
like this because then your rates don't
depend on the structure of the network
all right and so
why might these gossip algorithms be
interesting in the context of of this
workshop for distributed
optimization and machine learning well
it's not necessarily
clear that you would want to do this in
a data center let's say where you can do
averaging reliably using something like
an all reduce but if you're doing
distributed learning uh say more in the
sense of the talk that nina gave the
other night where
your machines are really distributed
geographically across a large region and
so communication is unreliable then we
can talk more but i think this type of
an algorithm might be interesting it
doesn't require you to update and
maintain a spanning tree over your
network and can be done in a nice
asynchronous manner
okay and of course uh there's been quite
a bit of work in this area looking at
using gossip and related types of
algorithms for doing distributed
optimization this traces back to the the
seminal work of sit-cyclosportais and
athens in the 80s and more recently
there's been
quite a lot of interest in this area
including work
by angelia netich and her colleagues at
illinois and also his dogler at mit as
well as here at berkeley by duchy
agarwal and rain wright so the the work
of netich and and her colleagues looks
more at doing averaging in the primal
domain
and uh the paper of duchy agrowall and
wainwright looks at
doing the averaging more in the dual
domain in the sense of nestoroah's
dual averaging algorithm and that's
going to be the the approach that we'll
also adopt in the work that i'll tell
you about today
so let me tell you about an algorithm
now for doing
distributed dual averaging with
approximate mini batches okay so
um
we'll say that each node is going to
initialize so each node is going to have
two variables now since we're doing
nestorov's dual averaging algorithm so
we're going to have a dual variable z at
each node and a primal variable w at
each node as well and we'll initialize
both of those just to be the zero
vectors
okay and then we're going to repeat for
the number of iterations which depends
on the number of samples that we plan to
observe
we will
locally
compute a mini batch gradient this is
just scaled each node has b over n
samples that it's going to take in order
to have a total mini batch across the
network that has size b
we're going to run our approximate
distributed averaging algorithm where
the argument that we give it is
our dual variable plus this new batch
gradient
okay
and then we're going to put it through a
proximal projection so
h here is a strongly convex prox
function think of it as the euclidean
norm if you wish and this beta t
sequence is going to be sequence of
algorithm parameters which are non
negative and which are strictly
increasing
these are just the algorithm parameters
of the algorithm standard dual averaging
algorithm if you're familiar with that
all right and so again what we're doing
our approximate distributed averaging on
here is our previous dual variable at
node i plus this mini batch gradient
that it just computed
and so if we think about what this
should give us
it should give us something like after
we've
computed this if we've done our
distributed averaging and delta is small
we should all have something like the
average of these values which is just
our average dual variable from the
previous iteration
plus our mini batch gradient involving
all b of these samples right so this is
if we did this exactly then it would be
identical to the distributed mini-batch
algorithm of decal at all where we
aggregate up and down a spanning tree
but in this case this is going to have
some error so we're not going to have
exactly this
and so analyzing this algorithm involves
accounting for that error making sure
that it doesn't get too large
essentially
and just to remind us again during this
mini batch part of the algorithm across
the network we see a total of b samples
and then while we're doing this
communication we're assuming we see some
amount of latency mu samples as well
all right so what can we prove about
this algorithm
does it converge yes it converges what's
the rate at which it converges so
one can analyze that algorithm in
general for a general distributed
averaging algorithm where you have
general errors delta and latencies mu
and get a result and then we can plug in
things that we know for gossip
algorithms and so
in the interest of time if i combine
these two results what this tells us
is that if we run this distributed dual
averaging algorithm with approximate
mini matches and
at each time that we do gossip we use
the right number of iterations where
that number is k
the right number of gossip iterations
and that depends on the logarithm of 1
plus this constant so l is our lipschitz
constant of the original function b is
the mini-batch size mu is the latency so
b plus mu is the total number of samples
that we saw
throughout that mini-batch round
multiplied by the square root of the
size of the network and divided by the
spectral gap so it tells us how many
iterations of gossip to do at each
iteration
then what we can guarantee and if we
choose our our algorithm parameters to
be as follows so k which is the ellipses
constant of the gradients plus the
square root of t and now normalized by
the total number of samples that we see
in that that round
then
choosing that mini batch size
appropriately similar to the way that
you would choose it for the perfect
distributed mini batch algorithm our
regret also scales like order of square
root of m
alec
uh so a bit confused how the latency can
stay fixed irrespective of the number of
iterations we use for class
because u is being held as a constant
and k is essentially being set as a
function of
mu so
the the two depend on each other
yes i agree with you there so mu is this
number of samples
um
right
but if you're if you're using two
different values of k then
you end up incurring different values of
mu so that
yes i do i i agree with you so it's not
it's not clear from the slide maybe it's
yeah easier to talk about off offline
okay
um
but it'll come up in what i was i was
about to say now which is so if if g is
an expander
then this number of iterations that we
need to run is like log of n
and so mu is going to be like log of n
so if you put
log of n in there you have log log of n
times square root of n so this is okay
okay and so i guess what's interesting
for me about about this observation is
that
the latency here is the same order wise
as aggregating up and down this tree
right so it says we're getting
the same
asymptotic regret i'll say so we're
still getting this rate of square root
of m
and the amount of communication is the
same of course the constants are
different
and the reason for choosing this many
iterations is this guarantees that the
the error after that many iterations is
going to be low enough
right
okay
so this
there's well-known connections between
stochastic online prediction and
stochastic optimization
and so
we can consider a very related problem
which is to say let's minimize the
expected value of this loss function
where we're receiving random
observations of its gradients
essentially subject to some constraints
for example w being in script w
and so it's well known that for this
problem if you have regret rounds for
stochastic online prediction those give
you directly a bound on your optimality
gap it tells you that
the optimality gap after m samples from
your random gradient is going to be
bounded like 1 over m times the expected
regret
where here rather than just directly
using that dual variable we're averaging
our dual variable
over all the samples that we've received
so it's just a running average
and so
what the previous piggybacking on the
previous result is it tells us that if
we use the same algorithm and same
number of gossip iterations per round
then
well so now i should take a step back
and i should say that in the online
prediction case art we were worried
about additional samples arriving
while we were
doing this communication
now if we're doing stochastic
optimization in a sense we don't have to
worry about this anymore right because
we're
i would picture using this where we have
data at each node we're computing a
small mini batch gradient off of a
subset of the data at each node and so
while we're doing this communication one
could conceivably stop doing local
computations hold your value fixed and
then continue after that communication
is finished so we're still back to a
sequential algorithm but
in this case essentially the latency
doesn't hurt us here
and
so that essentially eliminates the mu
from the formula here and what we get is
that our optimality graph is going to go
down like 1 over the square root of m
and so
m is like
b times t but it's also proportional to
n times t where n is that number of
nodes in the network and so we get that
the the optimality graph is decreasing
like the square root of n times t one
over the square root of n times t where
n is that number of nodes in the network
t is the number of rounds that we've run
the algorithm
and so the
accuracy here in order to guarantee
accuracy epsilon this tells us that the
number of rounds of this algorithm we
should run is going to grow like 1 over
n 1 over epsilon squared in other words
this is interesting to me because if we
add more nodes to the network we
actually
reduce the amount of time it takes to do
this computation we also reduce the
amount of communication per round since
the number of gossip iterations is
proportional to the amount of
communication and this is going to go
down with n and this isn't always the
case for other consensus-based
distributed optimization algorithms so
it's interesting to me that in the
scenario you do get this kind of a speed
up where you add more nodes and things
go faster
okay
so the only other uh
i guess there's a related piece of work
by agrawal and duchy where they do get
similar scaling but it's in a very
different setting they're in more of a
master worker architecture where um
there they have to worry about errors
arising essentially because these
workers could be computing local mini
batch gradients using outdated
information so it's it's a different
setup it requires some different
analysis but this is i think the most
related result that i've seen in the
literature and so i'm just going to
conclude um
so i guess the message is that exact
averaging is not crucial to get this
optimal regret scaling if you have
distributed mini batches
and we just need to ensure that
the
nodes don't the values at the nodes
don't drift too far apart so doing
enough communication can give you that
the current gossip bounds that i
mentioned before those are
worst case in the sense that they assume
that when we begin doing this
approximate distributed averaging we
have some node who is very far away from
the average of course in many practical
scenarios that might not be the case and
someone could imagine trying to do an
adaptive type of approach where nodes
maybe decide when they've done enough
gossiping in order to stop early
and
now that we've got this in a
sort of this gossip framework where we
have approximate distributed mini
batches this really is a big step
towards having asynchronous completely
asynchronous algorithms i think it's not
a stretch to go to a completely
asynchronous distributed algorithm of
this sort so the
problem that's still unclear to me is
that at least in the serial setting we
know if you have stronger assumptions
about your objective if you know your
loss function is strongly convex then
you can attain much faster or much
better rates your regret only grows like
log n and it's not clear to me whether
or not that can also be achieved in this
distributed setting using approximate
mini batches but i think um it seems
like it may be and that's an interesting
open problem
so thank you very much for your
attention i'm happy to take questions
it's probably not going to be
the case if you stay with dual object
because
the best rate you can hope to get there
would involve
some
some terms that cannot be accelerated
with a one over t rate and then
sometimes it can that have a variance
push the terms that are not variance
dependent on one over t squared
okay
is he okay i'll try to talk to him
afterwards thanks for that
all comment well let's take the other
questions offline and thank the speaker
one more time